das neue jahr fängt so an wie das alte
aufgehört hat mit grosser verunsicherung
vielen fragen und heftigen debatten zu
angst vor einem terroranschlag kommt das
entsetzen über unbekannte gewalt gegen
frauen die neujahrsnacht in köln und die
reaktionen darauf zeigen dass etwas aus
den fugen geraten ist in diesem land
die kanzlerin sagte dazu heute politik
hat die pflicht die richtigen antworten
zu geben
aber welche sind das der silvester
skandal wer schützt uns noch darüber
reden wir in dieser phoenix runde
spezial zu der ich sie ganz herzlich
begrüße und ich darf ihnen meine gäste
vorstellen
oliver malchow ist bei uns
bundesvorsitzender der gewerkschaft der
polizei herzlich willkommen und
franziska giffey ist bei uns von der spd
bezirksbürgermeisterin von
berlin-neukölln herzlich willkommen und
ihr gegenübersitzt professor christian
pfeiffer kriminologe ehemaliger leiter
des kriminologischen forschungsinstituts
niedersachsen und dort war auch
justizminister ich begrüße hanna lühmann
sie es filtern redakteurin für die welt
und welt am sonntag und liebe zuschauer
darf ich auch noch ein frohes neues und
hoffentlich friedliches jahr wünschen
herr marco wenn wir das gesehen haben da
waren 120 landespolizisten 70
bundespolizisten und die können nicht
für die sicherheit am kölner
hauptbahnhof sorgen wir haben es
inzwischen mit anzeigen von über 112 von
über 112 straftaten zu tun
wer hat da versagt die frage ist
natürlich berechtigt die polizei die
aufgabe die bürgerinnen und bürger
letztendlich zu schützen
meine kolleginnen und kollegen die dort
waren sind auf eine lage gestoßen wo es
vorher keine anzeichen gab
insofern ist der vorwurf im sinn von
warum hat man nicht alles unternommen
eigentlich falsch die die da waren haben
alles unternommen was sie konnten aber
gegen 1500 hoch alkoholisierte und auch
sehr aggressive menschen können dann so
wenig polizist noch nichts anhaben das
schafft man einfach nicht das sieht
einfach daran dass die lage vorher so
nicht klar war
es liegt aber auch daran dass wir
insgesamt viel zu wenig polizisten haben
in den letzten zehn jahren sind 16.000
beschäftigte bei einem polizisten breite
brücke abgebaut worden
und das rächt sich jetzt bei diesem
großen laden zu wenig polizei es gibt
den vorwurf an
das investieren nordrhein westfalen das
verstärkung angefordert wurden ist und
dass nicht genügend verstärkung bekommen
ist können sie das bestätigen dass kein
geständnis gab die anforderung aus köln
heraus eine auf 100 euro also ich sage
monat zusätzliche vollzugs kräfte und 30
sind am ende dann zusätzlich gestellt
worden
das ist aber normales vorgehen
diejenigen die einsätze vor sich haben
macht eine kalkulation wie viel personal
sie brauchen wie viel sie selber haben
und wie viel sie an unterstützung
benötigen
das wird dann aber gefiltert und man
guckt dann wie viel man tatsächlich zur
verfügung hat insofern ist das kein
untypischer vorgang den wir jetzt in
köln gehabt haben sondern das ist die
realität wo die zeit fordert deutlich
mehr leute an als sie letztendlich
bekommt er immer das hören das ist die
realität wir haben nicht genug personal
nicht genug polizisten um unsere bürger
zu schützen was läuft da falsch in
unserem land wir brauchen offenbar
solche schocks wie die silvesternacht
dass alle begreifen so kann es nicht
weitergehen das ist ärgerlich die klagen
der polizei höre ich seit langem
wir geben sie selber weiter wir machen
forschung im einbruchs bereich und
stellen lauter frustrierte polizeibeamte
fest die nicht das umsetzen können was
sie wollen mit dem ergebnis dass auf 100
fällen nur zwei verurteilt werden das
ist für einen rechtsstaat nicht
akzeptabel
und hier ist das selbe bild wir haben
zusätzliche anforderungen durch die
terrorgefahr
wir haben zusätzliche anforderung durch
die internet kriminalität durch porno im
internet und kinder probleme und
sonstwas allem und die polizei wird
nicht verstärkt da müssen die
innenminister sich durchsetzen gegen die
finanzminister und anders auftreten ist
aber diese sache jetzt passiert in einer
zeit die sowieso sehr viele bürger
beunruhigt sind wir hatten eigentlich
angst vor einem terroranschlag in
münchen sind zu silvester nach der 22
bahnhöfe auch gesperrt worden also das
ist eine angst vor einem terroranschlag
da kommt eine neue beunruhigung dazu und
das gefühl der bürger sie sind nicht
sicher vdv ist man in berlin in berlin
neukölln ist man da sicher ich denke
dass diese sorge die erleben wir hier
genauso wie auch in anderen städten
deutschlands die menschen sehen wie
viele
neu in unser land kommen und sie sehen
gleichzeitig dass er
integrationsprobleme vorhergegangene
generation noch lange nicht gelöst sind
wir haben ja stadt lagen in denen gibt
es parallelgesellschaften dort gibt es
die auch arabischen großfamilien die
vielfach im kriminellen im illegalen
bereich unterwegs sind
das ist alles fakt und das macht den
leuten sorgen
und es ist ja immer schwierig man will
niemanden unter einen generalverdacht
stellen auch jetzt nicht auch in dieser
situation wo in köln auch ermittelt wird
wir waren überhaupt die jenen welche
gruppendynamischen prozesse sind an bord
abgelaufen
aber fakt ist ja eines es waren menschen
die einen zuwanderungshintergrund haben
und die egal wann sie gekommen sind
offensichtlich nicht verstanden haben
dass frauen in deutschland das gleiche
recht haben wie männer und das ist ein
recht auf selbstbestimmung der frau
geben das ist durch nichts zu
rechtfertigen ist wenn frauen auf diese
art und weise angegriffen werden
man muss ja sehen diese menschen kommen
aus gesellschaftlichen strukturen in
denen das menschenbild das frauenbild
ein völlig anderes ist und das ist von
unterordnung geprägt dass bringen sie
hierher und ich denke es ist sehr
wichtig ist eben ganz entschieden
entgegenzutreten
also eine ehrlichkeit die wichtig ist in
dieser debatte frau lehmann
wie empfinden sie das ja mit der welt
einen artikel dazu veröffentliche
posiert erinnert haben an diese debatte
um hashtag aufschrei das war die debatte
erste sexismus debatte vor ein paar
jahren geht ist es eine debatte die wir
jetzt haben und nach diesen vorfällen in
köln geht es darum sexismus oder geht es
da ganz einfach um straftaten und gewalt
natürlich geht es um sexismus würde ich
sagen weil es natürlich was mit den
frauen will dann zu tun hat die seit den
tätern vorherrschen
ich würde aber trotzdem sagen dass in
der aktuellen diskussion gerade so wie
sie auch unter feministinnen im internet
geführt wird sich einiges verquickt was
so nicht zusammen gehört also es gibt
das was ich jetzt so bezeichnen würde
als das oktoberfest argument wer ständig
in letzter zeit das argument auftaucht
es gibt ja beispielsweise auch bei
anderen massenveranstaltungen immer
sexuelle übergriffe es gibt
sexualisierte gewalt im alltag und so
weiter ich würde sagen ja es stimmt
alles aber es ist trotzdem nicht die
debatte die wir jetzt auf
die art und weise vielleicht führen
müssen naja wir müssen uns erst mal
eingestehen und mit wir meine ich die
frage ist ja auch wer schützt uns noch
und ich finde dass uns auch fragen wer
ist denn dieses wir also sind dass
frauen im allgemeinen ist das irgendwie
die gesellschaft hierzulande wie wir sie
zu kennen glauben in der wir leben und
ich glaube wir müssen darüber nachdenken
wie wir die wir uns dass er ist eine
willkommenskultur verstanden haben ja
jetzt was ich zu den linksliberalen
mainstream nennen würde also eigentlich
alle jungen menschen die ich kenne die
sich natürlich über das was man früher
multikulturalismus genannt hat freuen
und die prinzipien total dafür sind dass
mehr leute herkommen und eigentlich
zuversichtlich sind was die integration
anbelangt dass wir uns damit
konfrontieren dass er offensichtlich
irgendwas nicht funktioniert oder
möglicherweise nicht funktioniert es ist
der einsatzbericht eines leitenden
beamten der bundespolizei
bekanntgeworden der das ja dramatisch
geschildert hat der sehr frustriert
wartet seit 29 jahren hat er so etwas
noch nicht erlebt er hat geschrieben
dass die straftäter die man dann gefasst
hat haben aufenthaltstitel zerrissen mit
einem grinsen im gesicht und der aussage
ihr könnt mir nix ich hole mir morgen 1
9 oder ich zitiere ich bin sicher ihr
müsst mich freundlich behandeln frau
merkel hat mich eingeladen
also das zeigt ja dass es wahrscheinlich
ist es sich um flüchtlinge gehandelt hat
und das ist aber nicht so einfach ist
das wirklich klar zu benennen
warum haben wir damit ein problem hat er
damit angefangen dass der
polizeipräsident von köln in seiner
ersten öffentlichen erklärung gesagt hat
flüchtlinge sind keine dabei
obwohl sich jetzt deutlich zeigt dass
sehr wohl welche dabei war noch ist es
zu früh zu sagen ob die täter waren aber
sie waren in großer zahl dort auch mit
dabei bei den 1000 oder 1500 männern und
das wurde schlicht geleugnet und dann
denkt sich jeder hoppla das kann ja wohl
nicht stimmen warum macht er das
und dann ist das kurzatmig der glaubt er
um dadurch schützen wir uns vorwahl
problemen
wir wollen nicht den falschen helfen
indem wir sagen es sind auch flüchtlinge
dabei und die bürger merken das doch
dass das kurze beine hat und dass ihr
damit nicht durchkommt also von daher
war der erste fehler
das leugnen der zusammenhänge dem
sichersten zu altbekannte taschendiebe
die wir hier haben in großer zahl aber
taschendiebe gehen geschickt vor ohne
bemerkt zu werden
die gehen nicht mit brachialer gewalt
einen busen sondern nur an die geldbörse
also das war von vornherein alles
unglaubhaft und war kein gutes zeichen
für die polizei was wissen wir denn
eigentlich über die täter wissen sie von
den dem war mit denen sie gesprochen
haben das weiß man denn eigentlich genau
man hat ja eben gehört dass es einige
gab die aufenthaltstitel haben wissen
sie mehr darüber
es gibt einige aber wenige das problem
der polizei ist dass sie die
vorgehensweise der täter aus der menge
heraus passierte dass es für die opfer
ganz schwierig sein wird und damit auch
für die polizei ermittlungstechnischen
werden wird aus einer gruppe heraus
selbst wenn man jetzt auf einem video
die gruppe sehe genau zu sagen wer von
denen war das eigentlich sind sie sich
sicher dass der das war was trug der es
hat gehört dass die kleidung gewechselt
worden ist so dass es da auch von
vorneherein schwierig werden würde für
die polizei ermittlungen durchzuführen
also die palette ist bunt
es sind aber wohl auch flüchtlinge dabei
gewesen die zu mindestens mit diesen
äußeren diese zitiert haben und da denke
ich mal kann man dem einsatzleiter auch
glauben ja deutlich vor die polizei sich
gestellt haben im grunde genommen zum
ausdruck gebracht haben ihr könnt mir
gar nichts er ist die bürger hinter
respekt der polizei gegenüber es geht
jetzt nicht um das alte wilhelminische
darum geht es nicht sondern gaben die
bürger polizei aber die funktioniert nur
wenn die bürgerinnen und bürger auf sich
an bestimmte regeln erhalten sofern sie
das nicht tun wird sich polizei auch
hier wieder verändern
wenn aber die polizei da schon machtlos
war und die bürger nicht schützen konnte
wie viele möglichkeiten gibt es denn
dann jetzt überhaupt er sie zu fassen
und die täter zu fassen und zu bestrafen
weil es ist ganz schwierig und es wird
lange dauern
das muss man sagen selbst wenn man jetzt
von den 106 anzeigen im kölner bereich
ausgeht und sagt wir haben da auch
gruppen identifiziert dann heißt es erst
mal nur
sie kennen jemanden aus der gruppe aber
was der gemacht hat da steht noch gar
nicht fest
und selbst wenn es dann aussagen gebe
über der was muss das letztendlich
belegt werden das sind ganz ganz
schwierige ermittlungen und das traurige
bei diesen ermittlungen ist dass die
frauen ja wirklich ein schweres
schicksal haben als opfer und sie
möglicherweise oder sehr wahrscheinlich
neben der opfer werden durch die gewalt
hat das zweite mal machtlosigkeit durch
eigentlich den start der schutz bieten
soll
erleben und das führt noch zu weit und
traumatisierung das ist eine ganz
schlimme geschichte und ich weiß dass
ich habe selbst mit einer dienststelle
geleitet wo es um sexualdelikte und die
bearbeitung ging das ist intensive
arbeit bei der peiner polizei hier
gewissen ganz komisches umfeld was
schwierige ermittlungen bedeutet und die
polizisten die alle da waren die sind
zur polizei gegangen weil sie den bürger
und bürgern helfen wollen und die
erleben ohnmacht nicht weil sie keine
lust haben oder weil sie auf dem rechten
oder diesmal auf einem anderen auge
blind sind sondern weil sie einfach
überrannt worden sind und gehindert
worden sind tätig zu werden
aber das zeigt letztendlich also mach
das ist ja was was man nicht haben
möchte man möchte ja die polizei möchte
dass der staat ein schützt frage wie
wichtig ist es ihrer meinung nach dass
jetzt harte konsequenzen gibt es heißt
ja jetzt mit aller härte des gesetzes
soll es verfolgt werden ich meine es ist
das ist ja auch eine formel die man dann
immer höher das ist ja eigentlich klar
dass man wenn man sich strafbar macht
das ist gesetz entsprechend mann
verurteilt wird
das entscheidende sehr nett hat dass das
ohne ansehen der person passiert und
auch ohne die migrationsgeschichte die
derjenige hat und das ist auch der
anspruch den letztendlich die
bevölkerung ja erhebt dass diejenigen
die sich eben nicht regelkonform
verhalten da auch ganz klar etwas spüren
und wir sind ja an einem punkt wo wir im
moment und hauptsächlich konzentrieren
auf die notaufnahme erstversorgung bett
essen und registrierung aber das was da
passiert ist ja nur der anfang von phase
2 nämlich der frage wie integrieren sich
eigentlich die menschen die hier
herkommen und hier leben wollen und wie
leisten sie auch einen beitrag wir
müssen hier ein stück weit weg kommen
vom fall so
morgen hin zum bewegen und das befähigen
heißt auch teilhabe an der gesellschaft
und das heißt dass bestimmte werte die
dieses land prägen und tragen von allen
zu respektieren sind und das heißt
wissen sie dass durch wir müssen jeden
tag neu klar machen dass eben es nicht
geduldet wird wenn frauen auf diese art
und weise eben nicht in ihrer
selbständigkeit respektiert werden es
wird ja generell geliefert die polizei
ist er dann ohnmächtig das heißt ja ja
ich die wie in dem fall sind die männer
mächtiger als die polizei das ist
natürlich eine ausnahme situation
gewesen das muss man natürlich auch
sagen
und hier gibt es wenn man mal betrachtet
dass wir von einer million flüchtlinge
sprechen die in diesem jahr nach
deutschland gekommen sind es handelt
sich bei leuten die sich so verhalten um
eine minderheit aber diese minderheit
ist in der lage ein riesenproblem
heraufzubeschwören
denn es ist wasser auf die mühlen der
rechtsradikalen und es ist eine gefahr
für die integration insgesamt und das
heißt dass wir bei allen anderen jeden
tag aufs neue auch klar machen müssen
dass eben bestimmte dinge ganz
wesentlich sind die die frauen und
mädchen in ihrer in ihrer lebenswelt
auch haben müssen also ganz konkret wir
haben diskussionen in neukölln darüber
ob ein mädchen sich selbst in ihr
partner aussuchen darf ob sie die schule
beenden darf ob sie das abitur machen
kann ob sie ihren beruflichen weg selbst
bestimmen kann ob sie überhaupt eine
berufliche ausbildung man kann das haben
wir seit jahren diese diskussion
und da geht es immer wieder darum dass
man gespräche führt dass meine eltern
überzeugt dass man sagt so geht es nicht
und das ist viel viel harte arbeit die
fängt im kindergarten in der schule am
kahlen lebens bereit ist bei denen schon
nicht funktioniert schon länger da sind
ja die frage wie kann denn das dann
funktionieren im moment erst mal damit
beschäftigen allen flüchtlingen bett und
eine unterkunft zu geben was die politik
in den ersten tagen nach dem ereignis
geboten hat war leider primär verbale
kraftmeierei sie reden nur über das
strafen und über das ausweisen
aber das können sie gar nicht wenn die
polizei keine täter liefern wird also
niemand hat geredet über die
integrationsdefizite die hier offenbar
werden egal ob das flüchtlinge sind oder
leute die schon länger hier leben aber
es sind machos gewesen die ein macho
kultur gelebt haben
sich gefreut haben an der macht an dem
rausch von macht den sie da erleben
konnten wie ändern wir das nur über
kommunikation
ich gehe mal zurück wir hatten große
sorgen als wir aus anderen männer
dominierten gesellschaften starke
zuwanderung kriegten die muslime aus
jugoslawien die in großer zahl nach dem
krieg kamen die türken als gastarbeiter
ohne frauen die afghanen in großer zahl
und der spannende ist wir forschen seit
20 jahren über diese machokultur den wir
immer denselben fragebogen verwenden
und wir stellen fest je länger die bei
uns leben hat sich das radikal verändert
die gewalt ist deutlich rückläufig von
den türken die früher riesenprobleme
machen von den russen von den früheren
jugoslawen von den iranern war sie
sowieso niedrig und vor den afghanen
eigentlich auch das heißt wir haben
gruppen mit islamischem hintergrund die
wir gut integriert haben das macht mut
und der a und o punkt ist sprache was
wir gegenwärtig nicht erleben ist das
auf diese starke worte der kanzlerin
wir schaffen das auch dann die kommunen
in die lage versetzt werden das
umzusetzen
sie kriegen das geld nicht wir haben
einfach nicht genügend gute sprachkurse
und ohne kommunikation kom waren die
männer nicht ran
die wertevermittlung die sie zu recht
ansprechende klingt nur wenn man mit
ihnen reden das ist auch dann trotzdem
eigentlich der zweite schritt die
kanzlerin hat heute gesagt die politik
hat die pflicht die richtigen antworten
zu geben
vor allem an was wäre denn ihrer meinung
nach jetzt ganz konkret die richtige
antwort
die politik geben muss ich glaube ich
kann nicht sagen welche antwort ich mir
von der politik wünschen würde
ich weiß also ich weiß wie ich weiß
wirklich nicht was ich sagen würde ist
wir brauchen ein stärkeres zivil
politisches engagement das über diesen
ursprünglichen impuls der als wie
gesellschaftliches engagement was über
diesen ursprünglichen impuls des hallo
sagen es am bahnhof hinaus geht also
doch ganz viele menschen die sich
engagieren fall und das würde ich sagen
ist wichtig dass wir das wir dass wir
auf persönlichen ebenen auch einfach
weiter begegnungen schaffen
bei familien bei unbegleiteten
minderjährigen flüchtlingen
es engagiert sich weniger das volk bei
allein kommenden männern haben sie ein
bisschen sorge zurückhaltung und das
muss aufgebrochen herrn sportverein
müssten zum beispiel die trainer
finanziert bekommen die
arabischsprachige sind damit die in den
sport integriert werden können ich nehme
ein schönes beispiel hier in der nähe in
potsdam gibt es einen gesangsverein von
männern die sich einmal der woche zum
singen treffen die sind einfach zum
nächsten flüchtlingsheim gegangen haben
zwölf männer abgeholt die singen wollten
die die sprache nicht können und ist ein
riesenerfolg geworden die sind die
lachen miteinander die singen
miteinander muss man alles syrer werden
einige sagen ja das klingt ja alles ganz
nett
das ist aber eigentlich ein bisschen
verharmlosend verniedlichend wenn man
darf man sinkt dann zusammen unsere
nation steht integration ist kein
verniedlichung des as a und o dass man
mit den menschen reden muss integration
kann nicht die polizei machen sondern
wir bürger müssen unseren anteil daran
tragen zivilgesellschaft muster
mitmachen eins muss man aber in diesem
zusammenhang auch sagen jetzt bezogen
auf die kölner und die hamburger
geschichte selbst wenn da jetzt
flüchtlinge bei waren die duh der
überwiegende anteil sind wir
wahrscheinlich leute die schon länger
sich in deutschland aufgehalten haben
die sind also nicht erst im januar 2015
ab deutschland gekommen sondern wie es
wahrscheinlich schon viel länger
und da haben sich höchstwahrscheinlich
dann auch flüchtlinge dann mit in diese
gruppen gegeben also sollte ich frage
nicht erst was haben wir eine
integrationsleistung jetzt für die eine
million zu tun sondern auch für die die
jetzt da auf der domplatte gewesen sind
und wenn wir uns mal betrachten wie wir
in den letzten jahren über das thema
straftäter mit migrationshintergrund
gesprochen haben da war das für die
polizei immer mit dem makel versehen
natürlich ihr denkt rechts klar dass die
habt ihr in den fokus hier konzentriert
euch nur auf diese tätergruppe weil ihr
vorurteile habe roche profiling all
diese dinge sind gekommen wir haben uns
nicht offen über das thema innere
sicherheit und erhalten im sinne von ja
was bedeutet das eigentlich an wert in
dieser gesellschaft und wir mussten
höchstwahrscheinlich dieses ganz
tragische ereignis in köln und auch
hamburg haben mit der ganz ganz schlimm
betroffenheit der frauen um überhaupt
wertfrei über migranten zu reden über
andere kulturen und über das was wir ein
für richtig halten dass das total
versorgt worden in all dem 2 am anfang
dieser flüchtlings diskussion wurde ja
schon aus der rechten ecke wurde ja
schnell gesagt ja die werden alle unsere
frauen vergewaltigen und er wird es
sexuelle übergriffe gegeben dass da
haben viele gesagt ja das ist sozusagen
das was die neonazis da reden haben die
jetzt alle rechts gehabt frau gefangen
ich denke das ist sehr sehr wichtig ist
gerade in dieser situation zu
differenzieren dann kann ich sagen alle
flüchtlinge sind sexuelle gewalt täter
ja aber die die es sind ob das leute
sind die zwei wochen hier sind oder zwei
jahre oder 20 jahre die die gewalttätig
und kriminell sind die müssen auch ganz
klar die konsequenzen spüren und dem
muss nachgegangen werden und es ist eben
wichtig dass man die balance finden
zwischen einerseits der pauschalisierung
der rechtsradikalen aber andererseits
auch so der ideologische brille
man muss das alles man darf das alles
nicht ansprechen also ich kann mir auch
noch in neukölln erinnern an die
diskussion
fakt ist 75 prozent der
intensivstraftäter haben einen
arabischen hintergrund es gab zeiten in
denen sie das eigentlich nicht laut
sagen durften
und das hat sich dann verändert in dem
moment wo sie sagen dass das verändert
überhaupt nicht die situation immer noch
dann über 75 aber ich glaube dass es
wichtig ist für fragen wie geht man wie
fängt man zum beispiel an mit kindern zu
arbeiten die in diesen familien
aufwachsen und groß werden
es geht ja immer darum in welchem
werteverständnis werden heranwachsende
kinder geprägt und wir sind sehr
überzeugt ich bin sehr davon überzeugt
dass es eben wichtig ist die staatlichen
institutionen so zu stärken von der kita
bis zur gebundenen ganztagsschule das
eben das werteverständnis einer
freiheitlich demokratischen grundordnung
überwiegt und nicht ein werteverständnis
was letztendlich aus einer ganz klaren
überbetonung der religiosität herrührt
und der ganz klaren unterordnung der
frau und das fängt bei den kleinen
kindern an wo schon in der schule in der
zweiten klasse klar ist du heiratest
meinen cousin und ansonsten bedient zu
den jetzt auch in der klasse schon und
das sind dinge da muss man einfach
wachsam sein und wir haben ja die
ethnien hierarchien auch in der schule
wo es eben darum geht wer
wer steht unten da müssen auch lehrer
erzieher ganz anderes toleranz und
gegenseitigen respekt also ein thema
besteht auch die gefahr dass wir die
gesellschaft dann letztendlich jetzt
doch überfordern weil wir schaffen jetzt
schon nicht wir haben nicht alle die
integrierte hier schon länger sind wir
haben die probleme sie haben es gesagt
mit zwangsheirat all diese dinge die es
eben noch gibt wir haben jetzt eine
stark verunsicherte bevölkerung hat dann
die csu nicht letztendlich recht wenn
sie sagt es sind so viele und wir
brauchen diese obergrenze das mit der
obergrenze ist schwer durchsetzbar
das weiß auch herr seehofer das ist
jetzt auch ein bisschen politisches
profil gehabe entscheidend wird sein ob
es der bundesregierung gelingt die
anderen europäischen partnern zu
partnern zu machen dass sie auch
wirklich teilhaben und vor allem dass es
gelingt die außengrenzen der eu wirklich
zu sichern
da hat die kanzlerin ein großes wort
gesprochen was ein bisschen zweifelhaft
ist dass sie ohne abschottung auskommt
ich glaube nicht ich glaube dass die eu
konsequent die grenzen so dicht machen
musste sie die rein lässt die sie haben
will dass sie eine außengrenze
kontrolliert haben die ausweise wo
kommen die her wer sind die menschen
dass sie nicht einfach wild reinlässt
und diese konsequenz wird daraus
erwachsen und wird sich schrittweise
denke ich festsetzen
und dazu ist dann so ein schock wie köln
auch ein element was dazu beitragen wird
ein heilsamer schock oder ist es ein
schock der die debatte noch mal sehr
viel anschaffen wird was was erleben sie
wenn sie darüber auch geschrieben was
wir kommentare bekommen sie also hat
sich der ton verändert sich massiv
verändert also das ist auch das was mir
eigentlich am meisten sorgen macht er
sich zum aller ersten mal wirklich das
gefühl habe dass ein gesellschaftlicher
zustand kippt und zwar in alle
richtungen das sehr interessant ist zu
beobachten und auch sehr beunruhigend
und ich habe das gefühl dass wir da
überhaupt nicht mehr der inhalt des
gesagten wahrgenommen also was ich in
meinem artikel ja auch versucht deutlich
zu manchmal auf einen artikel eben auf
eingegangen von einer konservativen
journalisten die
gesagt hat ja eben lieber feministin wo
bleibt in euer engagement jetzt so nach
dem motto wo jetzt eben die dir
eigentlich verteidigen wollte links und
so weitere die halt jetzt übergriffig
geworden sind so wo bleibt euer
aufschrei und ich habe versucht es zu
differenzieren und was da an
also ist auch an e mails kommt die
selber dann wieder beleidigungen
enthalten sind wegen gardasee tier
gutmenschen jetzt doch endlich mal was
ihr davon habt dass ihr die muslimischen
männer die ganze zeit verteidigt habt
und ein artikel eigentlich keinen dieser
tendenzen und es ist erschreckend die
frage was macht man da als medien weil
dieser vorwurf der lügen presse des
gutmenschentums sind alle diese diskurs
fragmente die sich in letzter zeit so
stark verfestigt haben dass man das
gefühl hat man kann es überhaupt nicht
mehr aufbrechen
wir zeigen ja von einem gefühl also da
gibt es ja eine beunruhigung da gibt es
ja das gefühl die medien sagen irgendwie
nicht das was uns beschäftigt und da
gehen die ersten beiden interviews die
ich dem fernsehen über köln geben durfte
da fragt mich die journalisten bitte
reden sie nicht über flüchtlinge möglich
sagt dann brauche ich gar nicht anfangen
dann ist das ende des interviews dann
haben sich besonnen und das wieder
aufgelöst wo kommen wir hin wenn wir die
wahrheit nicht mehr benennen die die
sich andeutet es war noch völlig
unsicher ob pflicht ich habe ich auch
selber gesagt ob es flüchtlinge sind
aber ist von vornherein auszuschließen
ist der kölner polizeipräsident gemacht
hat das ist unerträglich wenn die
verantwortlichen gehör mit selber die
wahrheit nicht verlieren habe dieses
gefühl gibt ja eigentlich wenn man
selber in seiner berichterstattung
nachgibt überhaupt nicht ich habe nicht
das gefühl dass das sind sind setzen
sagen oh was das dürfen wir jetzt
berichten und was dürfen wir nicht
berichten und trotzdem geht der gleiche
vorwurf der jetzt die polizei dann
vielleicht berechtigterweise trifft auch
an die medien und das ist etwas wo man
selber ist schnell ist eigentlich das
gefühl hat das ist doch nicht so und und
und was ist diese angst der bevölkerung
ist es wird nicht auf die eine million
das schaffen wir vielleicht tatsächlich
wenn alle sich zusammenreißen aber im
nächsten jahr schaffen nicht noch eine
million liebe politik wie erreicht ihr
dass es nicht nochmal eine million wird
und darauf haben wir bisher keine
wirklich glaubhafte antwort mehr
polierten mehr personal werde der
polizei helfen aber was würde denn der
polizei auf anderer ebene vielleicht
helfen damit sie ihre aufgaben besser
wahrnehmen kann
also bei mir immer eine vernetzung im
rahmen von innerer sicherheit polizei
ist ja letztendlich verfolgungs organen
und im extremfall eben auch gefahren
abwehren das organ aber die fragen von
prävention ist eine ganz große spielt
eine ganz große rolle also wir müssen
letztendlich erforschen was sind die
ursachen warum hat es diese möglichkeit
in köln überhaupt gegeben und welche
konsequenzen wir daraus ziehen wir
müssen jetzt nicht diskutieren ob wir
neue rechtsgrundlagen schaffen brauchen
was ja auch ein reflex ist er öfter bei
solchen dingen kommt darüber müssen wir
nicht groß diskutieren aber wir müssen
schon an wir sind in als gesellschaft
überfordert mit einer million
flüchtlinge pro jahr also ich habe ja
schon gesagt dass nur ein teil
möglicherweise der ihnen die dort in
köln flüchtlinge waren und mögliche bei
der größte anteil andere mit
migrationshintergrund wenn die dieses
verhalten zu zeigen haben wir die noch
nicht mal integriert insofern wird es
mit einer millionen weiteren oder die
jetzt in 2015 auch schwierig das kann
man auch sagen finde ich glaube der
bürger ist reifer als für ihr das
glauben die ewige sofortige betonung
keine pauschalisierung aller migranten
oder aller flüchtlinge
ehrlich gesagt ich kann das gar nicht
mehr hören und ich glaube dass viele
bürger das auch nicht mehr hören weil
die bürger wissen dass es vielleicht ein
täter mit migrationshintergrund ist aber
nicht deswegen immer nur täter mit
migrationshintergrund erstens fahren wir
zurück an die flüchtlinge aus
jugoslawien ein großer teil ist wieder
zurückgegangen als der krieg vorbei war
und sie wieder ihre heimat in besitz
nehmen konnten müssen alles darauf
hinwirken dass diese krisenherde aus
denen die menschen kommen sich beruhigen
dann wird ein großer teil wieder in die
heimat zurückkehren 200 deutsche haben
noch 68 kinder und können mit 47 enkeln
rechnen
ich glaube ernsthaft unser 47 enkel
reichen aus um diesen betrieb
deutschland in gang zu halten nein wir
sind auf einwanderung an
gewiesen wir müssen alles tun um im
eigenen interesse das die gelingt das
köln zeigt ist eine
riesenherausforderung diese männer zu
integrieren aber das sind das ist das
was die politik auch seit vielen monaten
sagt es ist eine große herausforderung
und integration müssen wir leisten aber
de facto funktioniert es ja erst mal
nicht vor gefahr jetzt noch einmal
konkret wie schaffen wir es dass wir uns
ehrlich machen und aber miteinander auch
wieder ins gespräch kommen dass wir
wissen was wir als gesellschaft
eigentlich wollen und wie nehmen wir die
dann mit dir hier kommen ja wir müssen
wegkommen von der dritte in der
turnhalle und das heißt jetzt winkt er
die zeit an wohnraum natürlich viel mehr
geschaffen werden muss wo geschaut
werden muss wo gehen die leute
eigentlich zur schule welche berufe
können überhaupt anerkannt werden was
können sie überhaupt welche deutsch
kurse werden angeboten
diese konkreten dinge wir haben gehen
davon aus dass wir im nächsten jahr
mehrere tausend neukunden haben werden
bei uns im sozialamt in den jobcentern
das sind menschen die eigentlich dem
arbeitsmarkt zugeführt werden müssen
können sie aber gar nicht weil sie
natürlich gar nicht über die
sprachlichen fähigkeiten verfügen wir
haben alleine bei uns im bezirk über 600
deutschkurse im letzten jahr angeboten
das ist schon sehr sehr viel und das ist
natürlich auch nur ein anfang und das
muss in konkreten dingen wir brauchen
das will ich einfach gerne unterstützen
wir brauchen einfach die leute vor ort
dies machen und ganz entscheidend ist
aus meiner sicht auch für die akzeptanz
in der bevölkerung dass wir nicht den
eindruck erwecken erstens wir haben die
sache überhaupt nicht im griff also
sprich die da oben kriegen das nicht hin
und das zweite es gibt nur noch das
thema flüchtlinge
denn der normaler mensch möchte einfach
dass er im bürgeramt ganz normal bedient
wird das seine kinder normal in die
schule gehen und dass er selbst eine
turnhalle hat für seine kinder für
seinen verein schauen wo er sport machen
aber dann machen wir's mal konkret frau
gitta nach dieser nacht jetzt in köln
und in hamburg gab es auch fälle in
stuttgart was raten sie eltern deren ja
pubertierenden töchter 15 16 17
eigentlich abends ausgehen sollen die
das noch tun ist es jetzt zu gefährlich
also ich glaube es ist nicht gut wenn
man so eine atmosphäre der angst ständig
herbeiredet also es ist
in köln etwas unsagbares und untragbares
passiert aber davon ist nicht eine
situation in deutschland wo wir von
einer generellen unsicherheit immer dann
wenn man irgendwo einem zweck geht
sprechen können also das finde ich eine
oberbürgermeisterin gibt
verhaltensregeln gibt frauen
verhaltensregeln länger distanz waren
sie sollen ja nicht um den hals fallen
jetzt im karneval nagel frau das jetzt
selber was christliches erlebt was ihre
aussagen prägt du dich sagen vorsicht
bedeutet also der muss sich ändern die
frauen oder wie ändern wir die männer
ziemlich genau das gleiche wie wenn man
sagt frauen sollten ein kopftuch tragen
damit sie ihre reize nicht zeigen ja
oder wenn mir jemand nicht die hand gibt
weil ich eine frau bin ist für mich da
auch eine grenze und ich finde einfach
das ist auch als er die gleiche argument
als wunder ja die hatte ja einen kurzen
rock an ist ja klar da muss er sich
nicht wundern ja also wenn wir so weit
kommen dass man das ist ja auch eine
form von freiheit in diesem land und von
selbstbestimmtheit es ist ja jetzt da
ist es gab also warum sagt die
oberbürgermeisterin so was ich glaube
das war wirklich aus der situation
heraus und durch ihre eigene prägung
aber das kann natürlich keinen keinen
handlungsleitfaden sein für uns alle
also so ein land wollen wir nicht noch
etwas ergänzen kleinen punkt wirklich
klein alles was sie gesagt haben kostet
geld wir hatten im letzten jahr die
größten steuereinnahmen der geschichte
unseres landes eine kanzlerin die sagt
wir schaffen das muss die kommunen muss
sie in die lage versetzen das ist auch
wirklich bewältigen können sie haben
nicht genug geld abgekriegt von diesem
riesen steuereinnahmen des letzten
jahres das muss sich ändern wenn köln
dazu beiträgt wäre es wunderbar
verhaltensregeln auch für die frauen
kontrolle man wie haben sie das
empfunden diese verhaltensregeln die die
oberbürgermeisterin reger er ausgegeben
hat
willkommen herr partner abhängig ist wer
es auch immer wieder erschreckend ist
wie wenig bewusstsein eben dafür da ist
das also dass die verantwortung dafür
dass sexualisierte gewalt nicht
geschieht eben natürlich nicht auf
seiten der opfer liegt ja und man denkt
dann immer wieder irgendwie da hat doch
jetzt schon jahre und jahrzehntelang
irgendwie eine diskussion stattgefunden
dass es eigentlich im bewusstsein der
leute angekommen ist dass zumindest in
dem moment in dem es dann
öffentlichkeitswirksam wird man nicht
solche wüsten klischee ist bestätigt
also mir ist es mir ist es nicht
erklärbar und gibt es darum gut durch
sie sich ganz persönlich auch vielleicht
verunsicherter fühlen wenn sie jetzt
hier in berlin mit der s-bahn mit u-bahn
unterwegs sind
das problem dieser ganzen werden ganz
nah dass ich wohne auch in neukölln
hermannstraße und ich hab überhaupt nie
irgendwie ein gefühl von bedrohung ist
natürlich auch ein sehr subjektiver
eindruck aus dem mann überhaupt gar
nichts immerhin kann natürlich für
andere frauen oder für andere menschen
ganz anders aussehen kann aber ich kann
also dass auf jeden fall so sagen dass
ich nie auch nur ansatzweise irgendwie
das gefühl hatte dass irgendeine art von
bedrohung ist und ich habe das auch
generell ich aber natürlich haben dass
menschen und frauen und in dem moment
ist es auch politisch relevant und das
ist aber bei der ganzen auch flüchtlings
debatte also ich find ja auch schon dass
man immer noch mal ein bisschen
differenzieren zwischen dieser
diskussion um sexualisierte gewalt die
man finde ich durchaus auch
differenziert führen muss und der
flüchtlings debatte wird muss man
auseinanderhalten
der minister sprach von einer neuen form
auch eventuelle der organisierten
kriminalität der ersten aufregung wollte
ein starkes volkswagen ist daneben
gegangen aber ich würde doch noch etwas
ergänzen wollen pärchen in einem
einzigen punkt muss ich ihnen
widersprechen sie sagen dann anfangen
ersten statement es fehle immer noch im
kopf
1500 gewalt ausübende aus dem
muslimischen hintergrund
es waren ja wahrscheinlich dann so um
die 100 bis 150 täter also die große
mehrheit der arabischen afrikanischen
nordafrikanischen männer hat sich an
diesen exzessen gegen die frauen
offenbar nicht beteiligt weil die frauen
nicht alle 1500 beschuldigt haben
sondern eine begrenzte zeit
von männern die das ausgeübt hat alle
selbst köln sagt nicht alle die aus
diesem kulturkreis kommen sind
gefährlich
das stimmt dass das wollte auch nicht
ausdrücken sondern letztendlich geht es
ja nicht um die frage nur um die frage
wer hat straftaten mit sonden welchem
klima ist letztendlich dieses ganze
ereignis passiert und da muss man sagen
dass wir tausende 1500 hoch aggressive
hoch alkoholisierte junge männer auf dem
platz hatten und täter haben dieses
umfeld genutzt um ihre taten zu begehen
entweder diebstähle raubdelikte oder
sexualdelikte und darauf war die polizei
nicht vorbereitet weil sie diese
verhaltensweisen so gar nicht kennt die
polizei ist über diese fälle gab es doch
schon öfter dass dieses was dann so
antanzen genannt wird
das scheint doch in nordrhein westfalen
schon sehr häufig dass antanzen ist
bekannt dafür hat man ja die hat man ja
auch mehr personal gehabt aber das ist
die verbindung zum thema sexualdelikte
gegeben hat dass da sich ganze gruppen
um frauen fahren damit einer oder zwei
sich sexuell an dieser frau vergehen
können das hat es so noch nicht gegeben
und das ist ja auch die dimension über
die wir reden wir reden ja nicht bei
diesen 100 taten um die taschen- und
trickdiebe darüber müssen wir auch reden
aber das was uns alle sehr empört und ja
auch zu recht weil es dass der
schwerwiegende rechts eingriff ist
natürlich sexuellen in die straftaten
aus allen bereichen die sind ist
deswegen ist es auch ganz wichtig sie
fragt mir vorhin das müssen wir machen
ich glaube wir haben tendenzen die auch
zu tun haben mit der
bearbeitungsgeschwindigkeit von
straftaten im bereich der polizei im
bereich der justiz mit bei den
staatsanwälten und auch bei den
gerichten wenn man sich anguckt wie
viele delikte wie bei einer polizei
haben und bearbeiten wie viele davon
schon von der staatsanwaltschaft
eingestellt werden wie spät es dann
überhaupt zur verhandlung vor gericht
kommt dann wissen die täter ihre freunde
die von den taten wissen so
so gar nicht mehr dass da was verboten
ist getan worden ist und deswegen muss
es uns gelingen
an diesem beispiel köln möglichst zügig
beschleunigt zu guten erkenntnisse und
verfahren zu kommen damit alle möglich
zu gestalten ist wie das klappt
verfahren und bestrafungen aber nur die
bestrafung ist es nicht es muss auch
zügig passieren weil es emotional
einfach die verbindung zum ereignis
geben muss was wäre ein richtiges signal
vom gipfel aus ihrer erfahrung in
neukölln mit jugendliche mit
migrationshintergrund was beeindruckt
die dass sie sich ändern
na ja vielfach gibt es ja immer noch so
den spruch dir passiert eh nix also und
dieses nach dem motto richter man muss
auch mal im knast gewesen sein
das ist ja es ist ja nichts verschrien
es in vielen kreisen dass man mal im
gefängnis war oder dass manche
straftaten auf dem konto hat das gehört
dazu
und diese diese normalität letztendlich
im werteverständnis ist das eine das
fängt ganz auch ganz früh an in der
erziehung und dann natürlich auch die
die ganze frage wie wird eigentlich
präventiv gearbeitet ja wir haben ja bei
uns das neuköllner modell vor einigen
jahren ist das entwickelt worden noch
damals mit der größeren größen reisig
der jugendrichterin die auf gesagt hat
man muss erstens präventiv viel stärker
arbeiten man muss bei kleineren vergehen
konsequent agieren und man muss viel
schneller werden viel schneller weil es
ja in der tat zu essen wenn so jemand
szenen 12 weil sie nicht wie viele
straftaten im jahr so auf dem konto hat
und dann kommt irgendwann das verfahren
dann weiß der ihm manchmal gar nicht
mehr um welches vergehen handelt es sich
denn eigentlich wofür ich jetzt hier
verurteilt werde
und das ist natürlich psychologisch und
auch gruppendynamisch ganz schädlich und
das heißt konsequent aber auch schnell
würde es ihnen helfen wenn es mehr
polizisten mit migrationshintergrund
gebe ich denke dass es generell gut ist
wenn diejenigen die den staat vertreten
und in behörden auch in der polizei
tätig sind auch repräsentieren ein stück
weit wie die bevölkerung sich
zusammensetzt werden wir nach wie vor
eigentlich eine situation wo wir nur
ganz
stark migrantische bevölkerung haben
aber relativ wenig menschen mit
migrationshintergrund sowohl im
schuldienst als auch im staatsdienst und
natürlich haben all diese menschen
vorbild charakter und natürlich ist es
gut wenn auch gerade junge menschen mit
migrationshintergrund ihren weg bei der
polizei in staatlichen institutionen als
lehrerinnen und lehrer machen damit sie
eben auch sagen können also erstens
perspektive kann noch mehr sein als
hartz4 und zweitens ihr könnt in diesem
staat was werden ihr habt hier eine
perspektive und ihr selbst nicht in der
perspektivlosigkeit wie viele denken das
ist richtig dieses signal ist ein
entscheidendes
der andere punkt ist aber meine
kolleginnen und kollegen mit
migrationshintergrund sind nicht
diejenigen die die lage so eine lage
beruhigen können sondern diese distanz
häufig die die verräter sind und erster
aggressivität auf einer seite führen und
da muss man ja mal eins sagen wenn
jemand mit migrationshintergrund zur
polizei kommen dann heißt es nicht dass
er in die schwierigen bereiche gehen
muss sondern auch er hat dann genauso
wie jeder andere das recht zu sagen ich
möchte indem man dem bereich eingesetzt
werden
also dieses spezialpolizei mit migranten
die gibt es nicht aber das signal zu
sagen es lohnt sich zur schule zu gehen
gute leistung zu bringen um dann auch
zur polizei oder andere staatliche
einrichtungen zu wechseln das ist ein
sehr bedeutsam ein beispiel geben
also ich justizminister war ich der
erste minister in deutschland der einer
ausgezeichneten juristen türken die in
der türkei geboren war hier die urkunde
ernennung zum richter amt überreichte es
war die grösste pressekonferenz meines
lebens in eine halbe seite in der
hürriyet sie durfte in der türkischen
tagesschau auftreten es war ein fest für
die türken das eine der ihren ist
geschafft hat richterin zu werden
das ist der effekt den wir an steuern
müssen dass sie merken es lohnt sich
sich hier zu integrieren
die türken waren früher ein
wasserproblem ähnlich wie jetzt die
aragon sie sind es nicht mehr
dieser wandel ist wirklich erfreulich
und macht uns mut vielleicht ganz kurz
nach zum schluss in
eine schlussrunde dieser silvester ist
ja wirklich ein schock gewesen dieses
ereignis in köln wenn sie jetzt jetzt
fängt dieses jahr an wie sollte oder was
wir das jetzt ein ganz wichtiger erster
schritt bevor jetzt hier in berlin auch
in der politik alles wieder losgeht vor
gefalle was würden sie sich wünschen
na ja wir sind ja eigentlich nicht beim
ersten schritt also alle haben ihr seid
ja bis jahresende kommen so und so viel
und dann haben wir ein bisschen
ausgeblendet dass eigentlich das
jahresende überhaupt gar keine rolle
spielt für die entwicklung es geht
einfach weiter und wir sehen dass die
zahlen weiterhin steigen allein in
berlin am tag ungefähr 500 menschen
wir sind noch nicht weg von der not not
unterbringung in der tonhalle wir
bringen ja weiter menschen in
unterkünften unter die eigentlich nicht
adäquat sind und trotzdem muss jetzt
folgen was passiert eigentlich mit denen
die hier sind und das heißt dass sie in
vernünftigen unterkünfte kommen müssen
dass wir die turnheim wieder frei
kriegen des sprachkurse angeboten werden
usw
was finden sie jetzt wichtig damit man
jetzt nicht nur so eine diskussion auch
zwischen rechts und links bekommt
vielleicht ich finde es wichtig dass
sich die linke so positioniert dass sie
den rechten weg diesen raum überlasst
also ich find's einfach ganz wichtig
dass also dass das dass wir die wir
integration wollen uns darüber klar
werden dass wir uns mit bestimmten
dingen auseinandersetzen müssen und das
ist verstärkt kommen wird und ich glaube
dass wir alle machen und ich ganz ganz
wichtig einfach nicht in aktionismus zu
verfallen nicht in trittbrettfahrerei
und weiter die debatten sauber zu
trennen und sich zu konzentrieren
mit der bitte um kurze antwort
vielleicht was sie sich da wünschen eine
radikale verstärkung der finanziell
finanzkraft von kommunen damit sie
vernünftig arbeiten können wo sie bisher
nur die note verwalten aber nicht
wirklich gestalten können und ein
engagiertes kümmern um die opfer denn
das problem ist ja opfer muss kein täter
gibt kriegen nicht einmal nach dem
gewaltschutzgesetz all das was ihnen
zusteht staatliche unterstützung für
eine trauma therapie und ähnliches das
darf hier nicht passieren
also ich wünsche mir letztendlich dass
das thema innere sicherheit
den stellenwert bekommt die das in einer
zivilgesellschaft wie wir sind
eigentlich haben
wir haben in den letzten jahren vermehrt
beim thema innere sicherheit über
unabhängige demo demonstrations-
beobachter gesprochen oder über polizei
beauftragt das heißt also es gab
eigentlich immer nur den blick auf
fehlverhalten von polizei die
bewältigung von straftaten wie kriegen
wir das eigentlich richtig hin wie
wichtig ist innere sicherheit für die
bürgerinnen und bürger und auch für ist
da jetzt mal ob unsere wirtschaft hier
das ist vollkommen weggerutscht und das
gehört wieder in den fokus nach vorne
okay ganz herzlichen dank für die
diskussion das würde es natürlich noch
weiter beschäftigen und ab nächste woche
dienstag ist die phoenix runde auch ganz
normal wieder dienstag mittwoch und
donnerstag für sie da ich freue mich auf
sie bis dahin tschüss